the cost of auto insurance increasing
across the country especially here in
Nevada our state 38 percent above the
national average eight news now's
Madison Kimbrough is looking into why
these increases are happening she joins
us now with the details Madison
yeah the national average for full
coverage car insurance costs between 600
to 2 000 a year but here in the state of
Nevada our drivers are paying just over
twenty seven hundred dollars per year
and that's according to bank rate
we've never had any violations of any
kind when we got our last bill they said
well your insurance has gone up
250 dollars per car we're both on fixed
incomes
so that was substantial Dave Hill not
too pleased with his auto insurance bill
as of recent he says within the last
several months it has skyrocketed and he
was never given an explanation as to why
we started shopping around and then we
went with State Farm and it's half of
that for the same coverage
so we we just started to wonder if that
was an issue down here in Vegas
particularly Clark County Janet Ruiz
with the insurance information Institute
providing eight news now with why
drivers are seeing these increases and
what they can do to help themselves in
the process we've seen a dramatic
increase of cars back on the road after
the pandemic and increased bad driving
behavior Ruiz also stating that the
effects of inflation have a lot to do
with it there's Parts shortages so
that's increased the cost of Labor to
repair cars it's also increased the time
that people have to wait for their car
to get repaired so all these things have
come together to require us to increase
the premiums for auto coverage and as
for ways to combat the high cost Ruiz
says you should check in with your
insurance carrier on what type of
discounts are available also the
Insurance Institute for Highway Safety
gives out ratings on cars safety ratings
and those cars tend to get discounts
when you get your auto insurance
Ruiz also sharing with me that the
number of car thefts and break-ins have
also increased the premiums too now cars
such as Kias and Hyundais are at the top
of those break-in lists reporting live
Madison Kimbrough 8 news now thank you
Madison and as for the top five most
expensive States for car insurance
according to bank rate it is Florida New
York Louisiana we mentioned our state
followed by Michigan